[موسيقى]
300 عام من التاريخ
داخل جدران هذه المتاهة المبنية من الطوب اللبن ،
مسقط رأس المملكة العربية السعودية ،
لكنني لم أذهب إلى مكان مثل هذه
الفكرة التي تشعر أن التاريخ عندما تمشي
في
الحفاظ على الماضي هو جزء لا يتجزأ
من المملكة العربية السعودية  المستقبل مع
كون داريا في قلب
خطة التنمية للمملكة بمليارات الدولارات
للترويج لتراثها ، فهم
يجلبون الثقافة معهم في
كل مكان يذهبون إليه وهذا مثل
الجزء الأكبر الذي لا يمكنك تحقيقه
حيث تأتي الأصالة
بالنسبة لي
تحول المراسل المحلي afrabari hassinderia إلى وجهة سياحية ،
وهم يبحثون دائمًا عن طرق للدمج
في التراث مع الحداثة التي
يتحركون بها مع الزمن وربما حتى
قبل ذلك ، لكنهم يحافظون على
تاريخهم حياً
بالنسبة لي أفضل جزء  من بينها أنه يمكنك أن
تواجه تهديدًا بأن الموقع هو أحد
مواقع التراث العالمي لليونسكو ،
ولكن هناك أيضًا خطوات قليلة على بعد خطوات قليلة
من جيري تيراس حيث
قدموا مثل 21 مطعمًا جديدًا
لم يسبق لهم مثيل في المملكة ،
وهذا يشبه المزيج المثالي من
الماضي والمستقبل
يمثل تحقيق توازن ثقافي يحتفي بالقديم
والجديد
نقطة أساسية في تاريخ المملكة العربية السعودية نحن في
موقع فرنسا في بوليفارد ورلد
وهذا المكان مذهل للغاية
المملكة العربية السعودية بلد يمر
بثقافة ضخمة و
التحول الاقتصادي كل يوم نابض
بالحياة للغاية لدرجة أنك
تتغذى فقط من الطاقة التي
تعرض ذوق ونكهة
الدول الأخرى ، تمنح بوليفارد وورلد
السكان المحليين والسياح
تجربة غامرة مع مناطق الجذب التي حطمت الأرقام القياسية ،
فنحن على أكبر
بحيرة من صنع الإنسان في  العالم ،
الاستخدام هنا خفيف للغاية ، فهم
يريدون باستمرار القيام بأشياء جديدة ،
والحكومة التي يقفون وراءها حقًا ،
ويريدون الاستمرار في تحريك الأشياء ،
ويريدون
إعداد هذه الأماكن الجديدة للناس ليستمتعوا
بأنفسهم فقط
وليس مجرد موضوع  حدائق مثل بوليفارد وورلد
التي تعد جديدة على المملكة ولكن أيضًا
الأحداث الرياضية الدولية التي
ذهبت إليها وشاهدت تومي فيوري ضد
جاك بول لكنها شعرت
بتغيير الحياة لأنه كان هناك
الكثير من الناس هناك الكثير من
وسائل الإعلام الدولية هناك ووسائل الإعلام المحلية
هناك و  ثم عليك أن ترى نجمة
الملاكمين على خشبة المسرح وهي تنفذ
المعارك ، كما يجب أن ترى كيف
فازت هذه المواهب المحلية مثل أول ملاكم سعودي بأول قتالها في تلك
الليلة
[موسيقى]
تغير كل شيء وقد جئنا هكذا
منذ بعيد
[موسيقى] منذ أن
كنت هنا وهذه الرياض
لم أكن لأصدق أبدًا
أنني أعتقد أن هذا هو ما
نرحب به في المملكة العربية السعودية الجديدة ، شكرًا لك.